guys something amazing has just been
discovered in case you haven't seen it
some archivists have finally uncovered a
relic of the early 2000s my childhood
that's very dear to Dragon Ball fans and
cartoon fans alike and that is
[Music]
ajb in which they covered Dragon Ball Z
that's right Johnny Bravo covered Dragon
Ball Z usually in the show Johnny Bravo
would take fan calls they'd request a
show to Air and Johnny would play an
episode from that show except Dragon
Ball Z was a 24 minute anime so instead
of outright rejecting the request they
played the clip from the episode where
Goku kills Frieza but fast forwards
through the whole thing and just
commentates all over it okay now back on
Earth those Mannix dudes are
recuperating there's that Guru guy
looks like bad news
okay okay
they're bombing huh wow okay there's
that floating half body guy hooray for
archiving